FROM OTTAWA FOR "SCOTIABANK ED
GOT IT ACROSS AND HÖGLANDER SCO!
TA A COUPLE PLAYERS.
GAUDETTE IS THE ONE THAT SHOULD
HAVE PROBABLY BEEN IN THERE TO
GOT IT BACK.
TO THE POINT.
EKMAN-LARSSON SHOT WIDE.
PEARSON SIDE O
[Horn sounds]ER ALL THOSE PUCKS
BOUNCE OFF THE GOALIES OR GET
AROUTHE WING.
TKACHUK THROUGH STÜTZLE.
AROUND THE NET.
IN FRONT.
FOR HUGHES.
HORVAT's SHOT IS BLOCKED.
QUINN HUGHES TRYING TO GET
THROW IT UP AND
GAUDETTE IN FRONT.
TYLER MOTTE ON THE TURNOVER PUTS
IT IN THE BACK OF
PLAYERS ON HIM AND GARLAND LAYS
IT OVER TO MOTOT
TYLER MOTTE SECOND OF THE YEAR.
AS PEARSON's ON THE PUCK.
TA
HANDS IT OFF FOR BATHERSON.
BACK FOR NORRIS.
FIVE-ON-THREE.
CHABOT GIVES IT UP T
UP TO ALEX FO
LUKE SCHENN, HIS FIRSTACK TO HI.
HE CHANGES THE POSIT WITH IS A
STOPPED BY GUSTAVSSON AND TAKES
AN AWK
TURNOVER.
STÜTZLE GOES BACK T
BO HORVAT!
HE FOUND SOME SPACE.
GOT DOWN THE MAIL UP ICE.
AND THE SHOT.
KNOCKED OFF-STRIDE BY STÜTZLE.
HUGHES SHAKES OFF BATHERSON.
SCORES!
ALEX CHIASSON WITH THE SIDE OF
NET AND THERE'S A REBOUND.
GUSTAVSSON
[Horn sounds]
>> John: BRADY TKACHUK TAPPED IT
IN!O TO THE NET WITH
TKACHUK AND EVERYONE
GREAT GOAL! ROUGH THIRD PERIOD
THE LAST FEW